la violence dans le débat public c'est
l'objet de notre échange ce soir avec
franck keller porte parole du parti
reconquête et williams martinez ou
internationales de la france un saut
mise
bonsoir messieurs et merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france on si trop
habitués la bataille des idées est
devenu un combat de rue est ce que vous
partagez le constat droit en berger
williams martinez
je pense en tout cas que le niveau de
violence dans la société est quelque
chose de préoccupant
excusez moi j'ai le repos quand je parle
assez désagréable c'est de régler ce
souci selon aurore bergé je laisse site
il ya aujourd'hui un sujet spécifique
sur la crise sanitaire qui est en plus
très imbriqué avec le calendrier de la
présidentielle de 2000 22 et la députée
lrm de déclarer que l'entrée en campagne
d'eric zemmour a ajouté au climat de
tension extrême ce sont ses mots qu'est
ce que vous répondez à cela franck
keller
il faut quand même savoir à présent de
la république de macron virements
et par ses actions et par certaines de
ses paroles je vous donne deux exemples
qu'un présent dans la publi é mais il ya
ceux qui réussissent et ne sont rien d'
extrêmement violente
on n'est rien un président de la
république le temple il dit à un peu une
somme qui cherchent un emploi il suffit
de traverser la rue pour être vrai
extrêmement violent donc faut pas
s'étonner et
par exemple les gens et pour violon
par contre l'hexagone ont pas liées à sa
eric zemmour affirme déposes défend un
programme est en campagne électorale des
gens qui l'apprécient l'apprécient pas
nancy chacun doit pouvoir s'exprimer
librement est ce qu'aujourd'hui chacun
peut s'exprimer librement sans qu'il y
ait de violence à l'encontre des lieux
qui ne partage pas votre point de vue
alors je n'avais pas le sont là depuis
quelques minutes donc voilà je réagi
tout de suite
je pense que il ya un problème de
violence politique qui est en train de
progresser dans notre société et c'est
quelque chose d'inquiétant notamment à
la proche de l'élection présidentielle
et des mois qui qui sont devant nous
mais là où j'ai un désaccord avec mme
aurore bergé c'est que je pense que lé
une analyse soit incomplètes soit est
ornée de l'endroit d'où provient la
violence politique à mon avis la gueule
facteurs principaux aujourd'hui qui font
que cette violence politique augmente le
premier facteur c'est la question de la
répression policière des mouvements
sociaux dans notre pays parce que les
mouvements sociaux c'est une expression
démocratique et quand et là je pense
évidemment à la mobilisation et des
gilets jaunes quand on a une réponse du
gouvernement à ses mouvements sociaux
qui la réponse par la répression
policière parce que je rappelle ce bilan
c'est une 1900 blessés ces quatorze
personnes éborgné ces cinq mains qui ont
été arrachées nous quand on a un
gouvernement qu'il répond à un problème
politique parce que le mouvement des
gilet jaune c'est une question politique
par de la répression policière ça
contribue à ce climat de violence
politique qui est exacerbée et puis le
deuxième facteur que là je crois aussi
aurore bergé ne n'analyse pas en tout
cas pas assez c'est que l'une des
sources de la violence le politique
actuellement ce sont des groupuscules
d'extrême droite il va ça tombe bien
j'ai à côté de moi en tout cas un visio
conférence un représentant du mouvement
d'eric zemmour je pense qu'il ya un
problème depuis que eric zemmour est
entré en campagne c'est que eric zemmour
des complexes charrie autour de lui
toute une série de groupuscules qui sont
extrêmement violent je ne prendre qu'un
seul exemple parce qu'il nous concerne
directement non en tant que militant de
la france à sony il y a quelques
semaines sur les réseaux sociaux un
militant qui était présent au grand
meeting de villepinte et d'eric zemmour
qui a diffusé une vidéo ou avec une arme
de guerre il était en train de simuler
l'assassinât de raquel garrido et alexis
corbière qui sont des débuts de la
france a soumises et non heureusement
depuis on a interpellé le ministère de
l'intérieur ils ont rejoint depuis cette
personne a été mise en examen mais je
crois qu'il ne faut pas négliger ça il
ya une source de la violence qui vient
de l'extrême droite et on a aussi besoin
de de caractériser cette violence pour
pouvoir la condamner fermement et
espérer que les mois qui viennent qui
sont c'est encore une fois du débat
l'élection présidentielle se passe sur
le terrain des idées de la confrontation
des mots car démocratique aussi radicale
soit elle moi de par exemple avec eric
zemmour je n'ai rien en commun je pense
que c'est un candidat qui est raciste et
d'ailleurs il a été condamné pour pour
ça il faut que ce débat reste absolument
sur le terrain des idées de la
confrontation des idées et absolument
pas qu'il arrive sur le terrain de la
violence est alors puisque vous êtes
vous évoquiez l'instant le saut cadettes
alexis corbière et de son épouse raquel
garrido lecomte a donc porté plainte à
l'excès qu'en dire qu'ils avaient
demandé à eric zemmour de condamner ce
genre de pratiques et d'appeler à la
modération de ses soutiens socafl
candidat à la présidentielle dans un
communiqué je le cite il s'est adressé à
ses responsables vous ne fait partie ni
de mes sympathisants ni de mes militants
et encore moins de mes amis je condamne
par avance tout ce que vous ferez en mon
nom pendant la campagne je ne veux ni de
votre soutien et de votre aide franck
keller est ce qu'il ya un souci avec
certains militants qui se revendiquent
de votre parti ce que vous vous êtes
aujourd'hui débordé par un certain
mouvement
alors tout d'abord eric zemmour et
reconquête nous ne sommes pas de
mouvements d'extrême droite que les
choses soient très claires on n'a jamais
été et on le sera jamais on est de
droite républicaine eric zemmour a
toujours condamné les violences de tous
bords tous qu'elles viennent et rigueur
de tout responsable politique tout
militant politique il a par exemple
qu'on venait de le dire
condamné les violences de ceux qui se
réclament de nous de nos idées mais qui
ne sont pas du tout que nous connaissons
pas et ne font pas du tout partie des
personnes que nous représentons
effectivement il a fait ce communiqué de
presse le 22 décembre 2022 par contre on
n'entend pas les autres candidats on
n'entend pas aller les autres candidats
à l'élection présidentielle ou les
autres responsables politiques
concernant les violences fait par les
antifas violences faites par les antifas
savez c'est mouvement antifa qui se
disent soi disant anti fasciste alors
qu'en fait ce sont des fascistes
d'extrême gauche pourquoi je dis ça
parce qu'ils veulent empêcher un
candidat à l'élection présidentielle par
la violence par la violence candia
l'exemple essentiel de pouvoir
s'exprimer s'exprimer librement ou que
les français qu'on a pu le voir à
marseille puisse venir l'écouter
donc quelque part eric zemmour condamne
toutes les violences d'où qu'elles
viennent d'extrême gauche d'extrême
droite ou d'ailleurs
mais ses autres concurrents ne font pas
malheureusement ne le font pas nous on
est content les violences qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ces la williams martinez
que vous répondez à l'invitation d'eric
zemmour a dénoncé définitivement les
hôtes des antilles fin qui le harcèle ce
sont ces termes je viens de tenir un
propos je disais que la question de la
violence politique était quelque chose
qui n'inquiétait donc sur ce terrain là
je crois que je n'ai pas besoin de
leçons à recevoir mais je crois que si
eric zemmour et son entourage est gêné
sur cette question de la violence de
l'extrême droite si bien parce que il
est touché particulièrement par cette
question parce que il y a un lien étroit
entre ces groupuscules violents et eric
zemmour la vidéo dont je parlais tout à
l'heure avec des simulations
d'assassinât c'était un militant qui
était présent au meeting d'eric zemmour
je me fais prendre un autre exemple je
vais pas faire toute la liste parce que
ça prendrait un peu de temps mais justin
un autre groupuscule d'extrême droite
qui s'appelle les vilains fachos
lvf c'est un acronyme qui rappelle la
légion volontaires françaises sont des
français qui pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale ou volontairement rejoint les
rangs de l'armée nazie pour pouvoir
combattre donc là on parle de militants
néonazis et ben ce groupuscule fasciste
il était présent à l'inauguration du
local de campagne d'eric zemmour photos
vidéos à l'appui tout a été mis sur les
réseaux sociaux donc le problème que
vous avez c'est pas un problème de
condamner la violence en général parce
que ça tout le monde le fait le problème
c'est que la violence d'extrême droite
elle vient de vous de l'intérieur de
votre mouvement ce que vous considère
être comme une dynamique politique ce
sont en fait une capacité qu'à eric
zemmour et ça il faut lui reconnaître
que des gens violents et d'extrême
droite dans la société qui menace qui
parfois passe à l'acte dans la dans la
violence les bars viennent à vos
meetings viennent à vos événements de
campagne et ont envie qu eric zemmour
arrive au pouvoir c'est ça votre
problème troquer leur jeu laisse
répondre très clairement je vous réponds
nous ces gens violents d'extrême droite
nous n'en voulons pas si les personnes
effectivement se sont inscrits au
meeting parce que le mythe ring était
ouvert à tout le monde on ne les veut
pas on n'a pas envie
l'extrême droite ce n'est pas nous et
ces gens qui sont violents nous le
disons clairement nous l'extrême droite
on n'en veut pas nous sommes des gens
qui défendons des valeurs des idées par
contre je vous entends pas pour réagir
sur les antifas sur ces mouvements
d'extrême gauche effectivement qui
serait comme de vous également et là par
contre ça manifestement y a pas de
réaction de votre part donc clairement
moi je le retiens mais mon vol en
décembre mais non très précieuse entre
nous n'en voulons pas on a vu des
personnes si les personnes qui étaient
avec en photo avec monsieur mélenchon
qui était à marseille par exemple parmi
des antilles fin mais on va pas rentrer
là dedans ça sert à rien ça sert à rien
on condamne les violences on ne veut pas
de gens d'extrême droite avec nous mais
par contre 15,4 le motive n'apprendra
soumises accepte manifestement les
antifas où ces gens violents qui veulent
empêcher eric zemmour de s'exprimer vous
condamnez visiblement chacun de votre
côté là la violence faite aux élus la
violence dans le débat public est ce que
vous répondez alors favorablement l'un
et l'autre à l'appel de voir berger à un
front commun contre cette violence dans
le débat public
williams martinez à la france un sony
c'est ce que vous êtes prêts à faire ce
front commun aux côtés de la république
en marche aux côtés de reconquête
écoutez moi j'ai j'ai émis des réserves
tout à l'heure en disant que l'analyse
de roland berger était au mieux
incomplète et parfois erronées parce que
je pense qu'encore une fois dans la
violence politique il ya cette question
de la répression policière des
mouvements sociaux il ya cette nécessité
de bien d'analyser la responsabilité de
l'extrême droite mais tout cela étant
dit moi je pense que c'est extrêmement
important d'avoir un front républicain
sur ces questions-là d'arriver à se
mettre d'accord en disant que la
politique ça doit être dans le débat
d'idées ça doit être dans les
manifestations ça doit être dans les
urnes mais à aucun moment on ne peut
accepter que des gens utilisent la
violence pour pouvoir menacer les autres
et d'ailleurs je j'en profite parce que
l'a récemment c'est un député la
république en marche patrice hanotaux un
député de seine-saint-denis qui a reçu
par courrier des menaces de mort et des
insultes racistes voilà du coup j'en
profite pour le dire moi je suis
solidaire de ce député parce que même si
politiquement j'ai évidemment pas grand
chose à voir avec lui je considère que
c'est inacceptable qu'un député de la
nation reçoivent des menaces de mort
assiste aujourd'hui dans ce pays franck
keller comment apaiser le débat public
comment est-ce que compte y participer
votre parti de la reconquête est ce que
vous êtes favorable à cette idée de
sanctions ce fonds
c'est l'idée de doha roberge et les
sanctions qui seraient sans doute plus
dissuasif que de simples rappels à
l'ordre et à la loi qui existe à on n
lois qui existent il faut l'appliquer
c'est tout moi je constate une chose
c'est que laurent berger à une
indignation à genève à géométrie
variable parce qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est que laurent berger a fait un tweet
qui a choqué beaucoup de gens
un tweet dans lequel elle disait quelque
part que le gouvernement n'avait pas
créé de lits de réanimation parce que
plus il y avait de la pluie avait déjà
en réanimation ça ça a choqué des gens
et certains non insulter sur les réseaux
sociaux alors bien entendu c'est pas la
bonne méthode faut pas insulter en tout
à fait d'accord là dessus cependant on
n'a pas beaucoup vu aurore bergé faire
une tribune dans le jdd ou s'indigner
leur candidat à l'élection
présidentielle en l'occurrence eric
zemmour s'est fait agresser physiquement
lors du meeting de villepinte c'est pas
une insulte sur internet c'est pas un
tweet insultant c'est une agression
c'est à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
violent beaucoup plus violent et là y'a
aucune indignation qu une tribune de
roland berger pareil c'est la même chose
lorsque le 24 octobre dernier des jeunes
de génération z ont fait un collage
d'affichés à toulouse ils sont fait
agresser par une dizaine de personnes
qui les ont secoué qui les ont insultés
par et il est même perçue avec un
couteau et ces personnes sont reparties
en criant vive macron là j'ai pas vu
beaucoup aurore bergé réagir donc
quelque part quand il ya des gens dans
son camp qui se font insulter qui sont
menacés ce qui est tout à fait
inacceptable
bien entendu elle réagit quand c'est les
autres ton quels qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs il ya plus de réactions quant
aux derniers mois avec vos williams
martinez ce sera à celui de la fin comme
moi ce qu'ils ont fait pour avoir un
débat un peu plus serein à quelques mois
maintenant la présidentielle
mais je crois que d'une certaine façon
il faut accepter que le clivage est la
confrontation soit à l'intérieur du
débat politique parce que quand on
refuse qu'il ya un clivage dans le débat
politique et bah forcément la
confrontation se fait ailleurs à
l'extérieur et par la violence donc à
acceptons cette confrontation là parlons
des programmes parlons des idées parlons
d'ailleurs je pense que par exemple
emmanuel macron devrait se déclarer le
plus rapidement possible candidat à
l'élection présidentielle pour qu'on
puisse parler de son programme et
montrer à quel point il est dangereux
pour les français ça fera sur boucle le
même effet que eric zemmour quand il a
déclaré sa candidature
quand son programme est sorti on a
appris que mon eric zemmour il est pour
une retraite à peut-être 63 64 65 ans eh
ben c'est bien au moins maintenant les
français savent à quoi s'en tenir on va
pouvoir mener le débat démocratique et
c'est là dessus qu'on pourra trancher au
moment de la présidentielle merci à tous
les deux mais si on aura l'occasion
évidemment de revenir sur le fond des
programmes des uns et des autres merci à
vous williams martinez eaux
internationales de la france insoumise
merci aussi franck heller porte-parole
du parti reconquête le parti d'eric
zemmour